now to hong kong where graduating
university students have marked the
anniversary of violent clashes with
police that occurred during
pro-democracy demonstrations last year
students displayed enchanted slogans
that authorities have declared
illegal thursday's protests were a rare
display of defiance since beijing passed
a sweeping
security law following mass protests in
the territory
well joshua wong is one of the
best-known pro-democracy
activist there in hong kong he's
scheduled to go on trial
on monday and faces charges of unlawful
assembly and wearing a mask
during last year's protests
and joshua wong joins us now from hong
kong
joshua what do you expect from the
upcoming trial
in the coming months i will be facing a
maximum of five years in jail
for an authorized assembly and up to one
ridiculous year
for wearing a mask in protest but prison
bars
never stopped me from activism and
thinking critically
even in such difficult timing more than
ten thousand hong
were arrested since last summer and two
thousand people including me were
prosecuted
it's still important for us to stay and
fight are you expecting a fair trial
as we know how the court in hong kong is
being interferenced by the beijing
authorities
and how rule of law in hong kong exists
in name only
i only wish that during my absence
people around the world
can continue to stand with the people of
hong kong
by following closely to the development
no matter
of the uh canceled election the
large-scale arrests under national
security law
and the 12 activists being detained in
china
what about your next steps how are you
going to approach
this trial yourself
it's not easy to handle the pressure as
the one who have been arrested for 10
times being jailed for three times and
now i'm facing
six charges within three court cases and
perhaps the
time for them to jail me might come soon
but no matter what happened
to defy the greatest human rights abuser
it's essential
to restore democracy of our generation
and the generation
following us so in the upcoming future
it's still important to keep on the
fight
no matter urging the world to stand with
the 12 detained
hong kongers or how we keep on to seek
for local and global community support
we just hope to let the world to know
that even the prison boss or etc
is still also important to encourage the
world to realize that
the fight in hong kong for freedom has
not end yet
do you have confidence that the
democratic movement
in hong kong can still prevail
i have no hope towards the regime but
i've hoped to as people
and with the courage and determination
of hong kongers
i believe we could overcome the next
trend and
next term of the suppression
what do you make of the of the change of
administration in washington that's
coming up
are you hopeful that under joe biden
there might be more attention for your
cause
it's important for the new
administration to hold china's
accountability
when beijing show no respect on liberal
value and international order
i believe actions speak louder than
worse and we will note
the final results on next january and no
matter who
be the president or who control the
senate or the house
it's also important to seek for
bipartisan support
because supporting hong kong is not a
matter of left or right is the matter of
right or wrong and we expect a new
administration
to provide more detail on how or who
might be appointed
to be a part of the national security
council or who might be the next
secretary of state
mr wong thank you very much for talking
with us that was activist joshua wong in
hong kong
thank you